- Dans cette forêt des
Laurentides, des milliers
de hêtres sont en péril.
André Goulet, un ingénieur
forestier, constate une épidémie
grandissante de la maladie
corticale. Un insecte,
la cochenille, s'attaque à
l'arbre et propage un champignon
qui tue le hêtre lentement
pendant plusieurs années.
Un phénomène présent dans le sud
du Québec et en Ontario, qui
peut déstabiliser l'écosystème.
ANANDRÉ GOULET, ingénieur
forestier, Institut territoires
- Il y a des espèces,
comme l'ours noir, qui va se
nourrir abondamment des faînes.
Les faînes, ce sont les petites
noix produites par le hêtre.
Et donc, la disparition du hêtre
du paysage, vraiment, altère
l'habitat pour l'ours noir.
- La maladie n'est pas nouvelle,
mais elle progresse rapidement.
JACQUES BRISSON, professeur
Département sciences bio. UdeM
- Ça existe depuis longtemps.
Ça a été introduit en Nouvelle-
Écosse à la fin des années
1800, mais ça a progressé
très lentement vers l'est
dans les années 60 au Québec
Maintenant, c'est rendu
de notre côté; Montréal,
Québec, les Laurentides.
- Carolyne Collin se décrit
comme une amoureuse s s arbres.
Sur son terrain, à Saint-
Colomban dans les Laurentides,
elle voit la racine d'un ancien
hêtre. Une cochenille s'y est
attaquée danlele passé.
CAROLYNE COLLIN, ingénieur
forestier, Institut territoires
- Oui, oui, ça me fait peur,
toutes ces maladies-là qui
commcecent à... qui commencent
sur un arbre, puis là ils les
rasent tous comme qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé... ce qui se passe
encore avec le frêne.- Aucun tre
encore pour protéger ce type
d'arbre ou le guérir.
- On voit vraiment que
les écosystèmes sont très
perturbés, puis ce n'est pas
fini. Il y aura d'autres
espèces, d'autres espèces
exotiques envahissantes
qui cognent à la porte,
dont le longicorne asiatique,
qui cible plusieurs feuillus,
dont l'érable à sucre, imaginez
- Pour André Goulet,
la solution est simple :
diversifier les populations
d'arbres dans les forêts
pour augmenter leur résilience
face aux changements
des écosystèmes.
Ici, Charlotte Dumoulin,
Radio-Canada, à Prévost,
dans les Laurentide